"На вокзалах лежать тисячі людей, голодних і голих.
Потяги переповнені, кудись виїхати просто неможливо.
Ви собі не уявляєте, що сталося із багатою Україною -
повсюди жахлива дорожнеча та голод".
Так Україну 1933 року у своєму листі до рідних у Німеччині змальовує німкеня Маґда Хоманн,
яка опинилася в українському селі і на власній долі відчула жахи становлення радянської влади.
Історію Маґди у книжці "Любов і муки Маґди Хоманн"
розповіли її двоюрідний онук німець Петер Хоманн та правнук українець Сергій Сай-Боднар.
Починається вона у Нижній Саксонії після Першої світової.
Донька фермерів Маґда покохала колишнього військовополоненого українця Олексу Кучинського.
Але консервативна родина відштовхнула дівчину, яка завагітніла від колишнього ворога - і пара переїхала в Україну.
Життя у селі Каришків на Вінниччині мало нагадувало умови, до яких звикла молода німкеня.
А незабаром до культурного шоку додалася колективізація.
"Нас постійно намагаються змусити записатися до сільськогосподарського колективу.
Думаю, це щось на кшталт колишнього кріпацтва. Але ми противимося, як тільки можемо. Чим це закінчиться, навіть уявлення не маємо.
Релігія так пригнічується, що незабаром усі священники повідмовляються від своїх приходів.
Дітям у школі навіюють, що Бога немає. Від цього можна просто збожеволіти і більш нічого.
Думаю, милосердний Бог незабаром пошле погибель на цих людоїдів".
Як і родина Маґди, іти до колгоспів не бажала більшість селян. Тож, влада вдалася до продовольчого терору.
З листа Маґди Хоманн: "У нас забрали все! Щось купувати дорого, у нас немає грошей.
Ми не хочемо бути у колгоспі, тому вони зробили нас жебраками та обзивають "кулаками".
Хлібозаготівля тривала до 1-го січня. Це відбувається так:
10-15 чоловіків із револьверами заходять до хати та забирають все, що їм потрапить на очі.
Хто має більше, в того більше й забирають, а часто ще й з хати женуть.
Тюрми переповнені селянами, що здали недостатньо хліба.
Ми їмо відварені кормові буряки і кукурудзяну кашу. М’яса та жиру вже давно не бачили.
Чимало людей їдять коней та собак, але я краще вже помру. Ви не можете собі уявити тутешньої нужди.
Натомість ви, напевно, добре живете, адже наші продукти за безцінь ідуть за кордон".
Виїхати до Німеччини Маґда не могла - бракувало документів. У своїх листах німкеня просить брата Ґустава про грошові перекази.
За валюту та золото у спецмагазинах того часу можна було - утридорога - придбати продукти, яких бракувало у вільному доступі.
Так радянська влада використовувала скруту людей, у яких сама ж відібрала їжу, але яким пощастило мати родичів за кордоном.
Маґді і її двом синам під час Голодомору вдалося вижити. А от її хворий чоловік, знесилений голодом, помер.
А сама Маґда пішла в колгосп - влада таки досягла своєї мети.
"Усе літо я пропрацювала в колгоспі, проте в хаті немає хліба.
Торік ми ледь вижили. Голод був дуже сильним і цього року він наступає знов".
Під час Другої світової німецькі племінники Маґди воювали у Вермахті.
А її сини Петро і Павло - у радянській армії.
Після повернення з фронту вони не застали свою матір у рідному селі -
німкеню заарештували радянські спецслужби.
Подальша доля Маґди Хоманн - досі загадка для її нащадків.
Залишається кілька недосліджених речей: яким був її шлях від рідної хати до ГУЛАГу,
де саме проходили останні дні життя Магди та де покоїться її прах.
Ми зверталися в обласні управління внутрішніх справ, ми зверталися в обласні архіви, ми зверталися в регіональні тюрми,
у Вінницьку тюрму, в Миколаївську тюрму, ми зверталися в архіви міністерств внутрішніх справ України і Росії,
ми зверталися в (колишні) комітети державної безпеки України та Росії, в галузеві архіви.
Звідусіль ми отримали приблизно однакові відповіді: "У списках не значиться, немає що вам відповідати".
Але ми сподіваємося - вода камінь точить.
Тим часом на листи Маґди Хоманн звернули увагу в Музеї Голодомору.
Адже більшість іноземців, які писали про голод в Україні - дипломати і журналісти.
Натомість листи німкені - рідкісні свідчення іноземки, що безпосередньо постраждала від штучного голоду.
Дипломати, які в той час знаходилися на території України,
перебували здебільшого у великих містах - Києві, Харкові або Одесі.
І здебільшого вони описували саме ту ситуацію, яка була у містах.
Але слід зазначити, що радянська влада готувалася до того,
щоб показати іноземним дипломатам ситуацію кращою, ніж вона була.
Ці листи є надзвичайно цінними тим, що вони розповідають про повсякденне виживання людей в умовах Голодомору.
Вони, звичайно, є доказом того, що в Україні був Голодомор і що він був штучно створений.
Крім того, доля німкені, яка пережила Голодомор і Другу світову війну в Україні і загинула в радянських таборах, зацікавила і кінематографістів.
За словами правнука Маґди Хоманн Сергія Сай-Боднара, нині ведеться робота з екранізації історії її життя.